[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en este programa
abordamos con motivo del día
internacional de la mujer los roles de
género entre los más jóvenes las nuevas
generaciones están más concienciadas
ante la violencia machista también
abordaremos el convenio de Estambul aún
pendiente de ratificación en varios
países europeos por ello hablamos con
dos miembros de la comisión de igualdad
de género de la eurocámara la
eurodiputada Lina Gálvez del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenida a Lina Muchas
gracias igualmente y con Rosa estarás
del partido popular europeo bienvenida
Rosa Muchas gracias muchas gracias a las
dos por estar aquí en un día tan
importante según el informe global de la
brecha de género si se continúa como
hasta ahora se necesitarían 132 años
para conseguir la total paridad y según
los últimos datos de la comisión europea
si no se toman más medidas ya no solo no
se va a avanzar sino que hay peligro de
regresión Por qué es tan difícil avanzar
Lina bueno es Yo creo que es difícil
porque Son estructuras son instituciones
que son patriarcales que el hombre y su
experiencia sigue siendo la Norma y por
mucho que avancemos en leyes que estamos
avanzando luego también hay otras olas
que hace que se retroceda y muy
especialmente por ejemplo el covid ha
significado un retroceso porque ha
aumentado la carga de cuidados que
asumimos las mujeres de manera
naturalizada y la sociedad nos da esa
ese mandato social y al mismo tiempo
también sabemos que al menos desde el
año 2013 hay una auténtica internacional
antifeminista antigénero que está muy
bien financiada tiene estrategias muy
claras Y que está digamos
avanzando en
esta idea de que las políticas de
igualdad en realidad
donde desigualdad porque se trata
desigual a hombres y mujeres cuando en
realidad no están asumiendo un principio
jurídico básico que si tratamos igual a
los desiguales lo único que podemos
hacer es aumentar esas desigualdades
pero están realmente
alimentando Una ola antifeminista anti
mujeres muy conservadora que yo creo que
está calando en los más jóvenes quizás
porque
tienen quizás menos herramientas o menos
conocimientos para enfrentarse a esas
fake news en muchos casos no a esa
desinformación que les va llegando de
manera de sentido común y que bueno pues
pueden hacer que se avancen algunas
cosas pero también se retroceda
desgraciadamente en otras no
Bueno yo creo que efectivamente todavía
yo creo que se van dando pasos y que
España es uno de los países puntero en
materia del avance para
la desigualdad Pero es verdad que queda
mucho por hacer pero si vemos por
ejemplo la brecha salarial que existe
entre hombre y mujer se ha ido
recortando pero bueno todavía hay una
media de un 14% en la Unión Europea por
un trabajo de igual valor cobra
diferente un hombre que una mujer Es
verdad que hemos aprobado aquí una
directiva que obligará a que todas las
mujeres cuando las contraten sepamos si
el empresario nos Está tratando
justamente si nuestro homólogo compañero
hombre que hace un trabajo igual que
nosotros cobra más o cobra menos y
podernos defender no ante una
circunstancia de desigualdad pero luego
también hay una brecha en los trabajos
la mujer tiene mayor tasa de paro que el
hombre y no hablemos cuando hablamos de
mujer inmigrante o mujer discapacitada o
mujer que tiene alguna circunstancia de
vulnerabilidad Entonces ya la brecha es
altísima es muy importante la
penetración en el mundo de trabajo en
igualdad de condiciones porque es lo que
nos da una independencia
pensar que la conciliación el cambio ha
sido importante cuando que hemos
accedido al mundo de trabajo pero hemos
los dos accedido al mundo de trabajo
pero no los dos hombre y mujer han
accedido igual al tema de cuidados que
nosotros salimos al mercado de trabajo
pero con una carga de cuidados como se
ha podido ver pues en el momento del
covid donde claro Llevamos una
sobrecarga habitualmente porque no hay
corresponsabilidad en el tema de
cuidados y en el tema de niños no
Entonces eso hace que tengamos que hacer
muchísimas más políticas de conciliación
muchísimas más políticas educativas para
coeducar para romper estereotipos somos
las que un 60% de mujeres son
universitarias pero luego no estamos
representadas en los sectores económicos
en los puestos de mando o en los
consejos de administración de las
grandes empresas solo presidimos un 8%
de las grandes empresas Bueno pues por
lo tanto tenemos que ir corrigiendo todo
esto porque luego esa desigualdad no
solamente trae esas consecuencias sino
que además trae la violencia de género
porque la violencia contra las mujeres
su causa es la desigualdad y la
expresión máxima de atentado a nuestros
derechos humanos es la violencia de
cualquier tipo física psíquica sexual
que se hace contra la mujer y contra
toda la unidad familiar con lo cual es
verdad que Europa Cada día yo creo que
está legislatura ha sido puntera porque
la directiva de transparencia salarial
luego hablaremos de la consideración de
la violencia contra las mujeres como
eurodelito
la estrategia Europea de cuidados una
estrategia para la igualdad europea una
estrategia Europea de discapacidad bueno
Vamos haciendo avances Pero bueno queda
queda mucho por hacer y por lo tanto ahí
yo creo que tenemos que ideologizar poco
y juntarnos todos hombres y mujeres para
poder conseguir no perder talento porque
todas y todos juntos sumamos mucho y
mejor ahora mismo hacía referencias
sobre la cuestión de los estudios vemos
por ejemplo que también hay cambios en
las carreras que las mujeres que las
niñas y las adolescentes pueden llegar a
escoger según las estadísticas las niñas
sobre todo en sociedades con mayor
igualdad de género se desempeñan igual
de bien incluso mejor en matemáticas o
en ciencias pero aún así a la hora de
decidir qué es lo que quieren estudiar y
a qué se quieren dedicar vemos que las
mujeres siguen infra-representadas en
carreras técnicas cómo influyen los
estereotipos de género en que las niñas
cojan unos estudios y no otros Lina
bueno digamos las elecciones lo que
elegimos no tenemos una libertad total
en lo que estamos eligiendo porque
estamos primero hay precondiciones
materiales que nos hacen que podamos
elegir o no hay gente que tiene más
capacidad de elección gente que tiene
menos las mujeres en general tenemos
menos capacidad de elección Además nos
socializan en de una manera
completamente distinta que los niños
nosotras salimos ya con los las orejas
perforadas no de los hospitales no Yo
siempre digo es que es un buen ejemplo
incluso ya antes de nacer
nos la han colocado de un color o de
otro no O sea que nos socializan y no
socialización diferenciada que atribuye
Bueno pues unas unas características a
las niñas o que les da más valor a
determinadas cosas precisamente cosas
que luego la sociedad no valora a
nosotras no socializa en la empatía nos
socializan en los cuidados pero si
miramos los cuidados en el mercado de
trabajo son las profesiones que están
peor valoradas pero no son en sí las
profesiones los que está infravalorado
en esta sociedad es ser mujer y por
tanto todo lo que implica ser mujer
Entonces tenemos por una parte que a las
niñas se les está socializando en unos
valores que van a llevarlas a elegir
unas unas determinadas profesiones
también vamos a elegir en función de
nuestras oportunidades reales porque yo
siempre lo digo a lo mejor yo hubieras
querido ser piloto de aviones pero es
para entonces tenías que entrar del
ejército y cuando yo nací no podía una
mujer entrar en el en el ejército no
Entonces yo simplemente pues cambias y
piensas Bueno voy a voy a elegir otra
cosa o si tú sabes que ese
ese sector es un sector muy
discriminatorio o donde vas a tener
dificultades para conciliar y a las
mujeres tenemos ese mandato de los
cuidados pues dices pues voy a elegir
otra cosa rosa Antes estabas haciendo
mención a lo que se ha aprobado en esta
legislatura está pendiente de
ratificación varios países miembros la
cuestión la convención de istanbul es
una legislación que fue pionera en su
momento hace casi ya 10 años que se
aprobó pero aún así no se está aplicando
porque es tan difícil que algunos países
llegan a aplicar una legislación que al
final es tan básica para los Derechos
Humanos si es sorprendente el convenio
de Estambul España fue de los primeros
países en ratificarlo bajo gobierno de
Mariano rajoy en el año 2014
es un tratado internacional puntero
imprescindible necesario que
pone en el centro como objetivo combatir
la violencia contra las mujeres y la
violencia doméstica tanto la que se da
Pues dentro del ámbito familiar como la
que se da fuera y establece unas
obligaciones a los Estados miembros en
cuanto a prevención en cuanto a
Protección en cuanto a persecución de
los criminales Y es de sentido común que
debería estar pues firmado ratificado
por todos los estados miembros pero
quedan seis estados miembros que no lo
han ratificado
suelen ser algunos de ellos porque por
ejemplo Polonia ahora incluso ponía
pegas suelen ser estados miembros donde
suelen poner pegas a todos los temas
donde todos estamos de acuerdo porque
los extremos no funcionan y los extremos
no se ponen las gafas del sentido común
habitualmente pero yo creo que sorprende
que no lo ratifiquemos lo aplaudamos lo
cumplamos es muy importante el tema yo
lo he dicho antes la violencia de género
que es un atentado contra los Derechos
Humanos de las mujeres es la causa
principal de la desigualdad el sexo
masculino cree que tiene una
preeminencia sobre el femenino y
entonces esto se puede exteriorizar pues
con violencia física con psíquica que es
muy cruel consexual con material con
económica y entonces hay que erradicarlo
Pero para esto hay que tiene que haber
mucha coordinación se tienen que dar los
instrumentos y se tiene que visualizar
que es un delito de máxima gravedad por
eso también ahora Estamos trabajando
para ponerlo en la directiva como un
neurodelito de un ámbito transnacional
porque es un problema estructural no
pasa aisladamente en un en una clase
social o en un país sino que pasa en
todas las clases sociales y en todos los
países y tenemos que tener la conciencia
de que es muy grave en España hemos sido
punteros en la ley contra la violencia
contra las mujeres en el 2004 el
convenio de Estambul la ley del sí es sí
es una ley que Atendió evidentemente
buenas Pero ha tenido una muy mala que
ha sido posibilitar que más de 700
violadores o criminales contra la
libertad sexual con rebajas de condena y
más de 70 en la calle Bueno ayer hubo
una votación en España para que esto se
pudiera corregir y espero que se corrija
cuanto antes porque si no se da el
mensaje de que no es lo grave que
debería ser es muy grave y hemos de
estar todos juntos para para poderlo
combatir yo he estudiado un poco porque
estos países y muchos hablan de
principio de su seriedad muchos hablan
de que no le gusta el término género
pero bien Yo creo que son excusas bajo
mi opinión porque el objetivo es tan tan
tan tan tan necesario y tan urgente que
deberíamos Llamar a todos a firmarlo la
unión ahora en bajo presidencia sueca
creo que en junio posibilitaremos Ya
esta ratificación gracias a Rosa Lina
Lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo lo siento muchísimo me gusta pero
sí me gustaría decir que la ley del sí
la ley que lo que hace es cumplir
con el convenio de Estambul es lo que
hace y poner el consentimiento en el
centro y quizás habría estado muy bien
que el arco todo el arco parlamentario
lo hubiera apoyado desde opinas que
había nada de acuerdo
pero si ha sido mi propio partido que la
ha promovido por el apoyo
Estaría muy bien popular
también la libertad sexual y
reproductiva aquí en el parlamento
tareas También estaría muy bien que la
apoyarais en fin Muchísimas gracias a
las dos a ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy Gracias
por ver France 24 en español
[Música]